one large bomb with say ten megatons efficient
means according to the estimates of geneticist
that something like 15,000 defective children
will be born in the future children who if the
bomb test have not been made would be perfectly
normal perfectly healthy and my esteemeth - there
are some there are differences in the estimates
of different scientists my estimate is that one
great bomb test means the probable death by
leukemia and cancer bone cancer and other
diseases of something like 15,000 human beings
now living these figures aren't negligible I am
a humanitarian as a humanitarian I feel that
this is a matter that we need to think about
I feel that we citizens of the United States of
great rhythm of Germany of Japan of France who
have joined in this suit that we have a duty
a duty to humanity to do what we can we have
at least to try to try to stop these tests we
have to try to stop this terrible trend towards
self-destruction toward destruction of the world
that is going on now and this is one way to do